on any sort of you know basis I mean it
doesn't matter what you do whether it's
this show or it's a book where it's
another movie or a signing that has
nothing to do with anything that has to
do with Star Wars fans will still show
up because if you build it they will
come
yes have you ready when did you realize
that it didn't matter what you did
somebody is gonna show up with a picture
you with the buns on your hair and ask
you to sign it in any city that I
accepted it yeah there is knowing it'll
happen which has been pervasive right
accepting it has been like 10 15 years
yeah and they're nice people yeah mostly
and then there's some bit or not yeah I
mean it's something they're not nice
whatever that is they're just they have
other agendas like they want your
autograph so they can sell it right you
know this kind of thing and you learn
you know maybe be able to differentiate
and there's certain people where you're
in a place where it's not welcome yeah
but most of the time people are paying
attention to you because you've done
something that impacted them in a very
positive way yeah so you can't make I
don't want to make that into a negative
I don't know if you will ever understand
how much you have somebody who's just
meeting for the first time how much of
an impact you actually have on
somebody's life
like mine no I don't know if you could
understand what you as that person know
would mean to somebody like me I think I
understand past that that in combination
with my who I actually am combined with
that is a really heavy punch yeah yeah
and how would your daughter she's almost
19 almost 19 he's got it and I must have
been too yeah you know and like you can
say when you say the high is your eyes
or eyes yeah you didn't even know yeah
cause you're looking for you know the
flaw and the perfect thing yeah
are you close really close oh god yeah
have I been a disappointment to her at
times oh yeah really but she she's
fluent and Kerri speak yeah that's not a
really easy sort of dial up I did what
did she think of this initially you know
I did go to her and say anything a
problem and I'll take it out the
obviously the only thing that would be a
problem for us anything about her father
and I will never write anything else
about him but the thing is you know
having been told that you turn someone
gay very tough to keep that out of your
show but that you know that isn't very
you know that's embarrassing when we
were all very young when this stuff out
Brian is not someone who I think now
would ever you know tell someone that
they did that yeah but when I was young
that was something he said and so but
you know and I can understand Billy
being embarrassed but what she'll get
with time is hey I'm not gonna write
about stuff that impacts on her as much
as best day as I can yeah and B I'm
really not gonna write about him yeah
except you know just things in general I
mean it's more balanced now also I write
positive it's not only I dunno I you
know he was he was a real really good
person with certain the guy Brian has
his father living in his house with
diabetes without legs
yeah that's a good first